STEPHEN CARPENTER:
Part of what I
do is work with people
who are preparing
to be K-12 art teachers.
I actually work with artists.
I've taught studio-based
courses in ceramics, drawing.
And I'm also working
with grad students who
are interested in engaging
in research about and through
and within art practices,
visual cultural practices.
So there's this range of
folks with whom I'm working.
So one of your--
I'm trying to negotiate
a place to enter, Larry.
And one of the
things that you said
was how explicit am I with,
as we've been calling it,
this hidden agenda,
a hidden curriculum?
LARRY SUSSKIND: Not as an agenda
STEPHEN CARPENTER: No, but
it's the same thing, right?
In many cases, it's
the same thing, right?
Because you have an agenda
that you're trying to cover,
whether it's an
official agenda, we
can correlate that to
the official curriculum.
And I'm pulling this term,
these curriculum pieces
from the work of George
Posner and others,
where you might consider there
are five kinds of curriculum
that are happening at
the same time, five
concurrent curricula.
He says there's the
official curriculum, which
is what is written down.
It's that officially mandated.
This is what will be taught.
Then there there's the
operational curriculum.
It's what you put into practice,
trying to operationalize it.
So it would be the
official agenda, then
the operationalized agenda.
So agenda and curriculum to
me, agenda gets a bad rap,
I think, just like propaganda.
But that's a different
kettle of horses.
OK.
So then the third curriculum
that Posner talks about
is the hidden curriculum,
what is not official,
what is not officially
written down and intended,
and what also is not necessarily
operationalized intentionally.
But it is what is hidden
and gets learned and taught
at the same time.
The fourth would then
be the null curriculum,
what is not taught, what is
not intended to be taught,
what is absent and
explicitly missing.
And then the fifth is
the extracurriculum.
It doesn't happen inside
those intentional spaces
that we might think is
formalized schooling.
So if we think of-- you're
on the volleyball team.
That's extracurricular, but it's
still related to that education
space.
All five of those things
are happening all the time.
So the hidden agenda, the hidden
curriculum is one that I--
and there's some tension
there, because in some cases,
it's operationalized with
a conscious awareness
that it's hidden.
I'm not going to be
explicit about it.
But then there can be
a hidden curriculum
where it's being
taught and learned
without the intention of it
being taught and learned.
So when we ask kids to--
for example, there
are bathrooms--
when I was a kid,
gendered bathrooms,
men's bathroom when
we're boys and girls,
and so it's teaching us
certain things about how
society is structured.
But when we move
and have a shift
in our cultural and social
space where bathrooms
don't have to have certain
labels, then other knowledge,
other ideas are taught and
learned through those gestures.
But they're not
necessarily official.
Does that make sense?
LARRY SUSSKIND: Yeah.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: OK.
So the program where I teach
at Penn State for an art
education, also at VCFA,
we're very explicit about what
that hidden agenda might be.
It's to the point where
it's not hidden at all.
It's very upfront.
It's very official.
And it gets
operationalized in terms
of a focus on social justice,
a focus on the role of artists
and art in the world
and what matters matter
and how we can engage
with concepts and theories
like we heard in the
introduction-- feminist theory
or critical race theory
or critical pedagogy.
Or we can think about
anti-racist theory.
So we can think about--
or disability studies--
all of these different ways
in which society operates
are part of the
curriculum that I've
been part of in these
two institutions
to look at the
preparation of teachers.
So someone who says, hey, I want
to go study in this program,
it's not a surprise
to them when we
start talking about feminist
pedagogy and feminist issues.
What might be a
surprise is perhaps
the ways in which we approach
that and then operationalize
it.
But it shouldn't be a surprise.
Now in some cases, some
people might not always
read the [LAUGHS]
the fine print.
And then there might
be a surprise there.
But I don't hide those issues.
As a matter of fact, I'm very
upfront with my undergraduates
about, in this course, we're
going to learn about learning.
And I'm more interested in
learning than I am in teaching.
And that doesn't
make sense to a lot
of people who are preparing
to be teachers or think
about teaching, because to
frame it around learning
suggests there's a shift from
the agency of the teacher
as the primary vehicle
to the student.
LARRY SUSSKIND: Do I
need a first course
where there's no
interference with learning
to draw in a basic way?
And then after that, I can come
to a second level drawing class
where you can lay on
all this other stuff.
Or from the very
beginning, in even the most
rudimentary learning
of the medium,
are you already insinuating into
the design of this curriculum
this other set of concerns?
I don't even have
to know anything
about the basics independent
of this second concern
to start learning this
other set of things?
STEPHEN CARPENTER: No.
One can enter with the concerns.
LARRY SUSSKIND: And that is
your plan, most of the time?
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
All of the time.
LARRY SUSSKIND: All the time.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: All the time.
LARRY SUSSKIND: All right.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: So [CHUCKLES]
we start with, let's say,
social issues.
Or let's say we're grounding the
course within a social space.
We all live in a social space.
We all come with
a set of concerns.
We all come with a
set of experiences.
We come to the studio, and
then return to wherever
we were before that.
What we experience
outside of the studio
is content for art-making.
It's content for
engagement through art.
So this is a shift
where we think of--
so if we take a step back
to notions of curriculum,
a very basic question in
curriculum design, creating
theory, curriculum
development, I should say,
is what is worth knowing?
What content do we
want students to learn?
What is worth knowing?
We might then look
through the progression
of curriculum theory.
And then folks 30,
40 years ago start
making a shift in [INAUDIBLE].
What is worthwhile?
What matters?
And what happens is
there's a movement away
from a more modernist
notion of art
as material-based to art as
a reflection and engagement
within the world.
Not that it hadn't
been that way before.
But that the world becomes
an art-making medium,
and in a context that can be
not only reflected and depicted,
but can also be used
as one of the materials
within art-making practice.
And that art practice
can have some sort
of engaged and intentional
effect within that.
So the kind of drawing
class that you're mentioning
or describing is not uncommon.
These kinds of courses
happen quite often.
But their titles don't
always reflect that.
And many art schools
are making some shifts.
I had mentioned to a colleague
a number of years ago,
I said, we really need to
change the names of some
of these courses.
Like, we should have Art with
Larry, Art 505, Art with Larry,
and then Art 507,
Art with Steve.
And they would have a sense
of what that course was about.
It it's not a materials-specific
course, although it could be.
But when we move the focus
to issues, ideas, concerns,
engagements, problems, ideas,
that is an easier entry
point for the kinds of pedagogy
that we're talking about,
that lend themselves
to the sensibilities
of disruptive practices,
of social consciousness,
of transformative learning.
LARRY SUSSKIND: And what
I've taken from your comments
on occasion is that I ought
to have that objective if I'm
going to teach people about
operating in their community.
Don't just teach the
method or the content.
But get to this other level and
build that into the curriculum.
Take responsibility for that.
Be explicit about it.
Be accountable not just
during but even before,
although who knows whether
they would have let me anywhere
near the place if I had
said at the beginning,
our goal here is to bring
about change in this community.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Well, it
depends on your strategy there,
right?
So if we think
about it this way.
Now you didn't mention
this in your story.
But I would be interested
in this component,
because it also then
gets back to one
of those parts of the
longer question you asked me
earlier about my own
students and my own teaching.
This is part of the
social studies curriculum?
LARRY SUSSKIND: Yes.
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
Officially, right?
There should be some objectives.
There should be some state
standards or district standards
or district objectives
that many teachers
consider to be the curriculum.
And they teach to
those standards
or to those objectives.
I teach my students,
put those aside.
Let's build on what you
know, what is most important,
build on your own
politics, build on the--
let's start with the themes
and the ideas and the concerns
that you have.
Build your curriculum
around that,
drawing on your art practice,
your knowledge of art.
And then let's compare.
Let's use those standards
or those objectives
as an assessment.
Now how many of
those do we address?
Usually we can
cover all of those.
But if we start the
other way around,
we start with learning Objective
6 and learning Objective 8,
and this is the
lesson, it's going
to be really narrow and tight.
And it doesn't-- and you're
always going to be interested
in we got to kick it
back into the center.
We got to make sure they're--
But in the way that you
did it, I would imagine
you could have said
at any given moment,
when you felt some
resistance, well,
if we look at the
standards, we're
covering XYZ, 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6 7, because--
and this is a way that one--
I'm not trying to say this is
how you do a cover-up story.
But this is how you can
justify the social practice,
social engagement, social
consciousness pedagogy
is you say, look, we're
meeting all of the standards.
As a matter of fact, if
we were to do, let's say,
three units like this over
the course of the year,
we could hit all of those
objectives each time.
If we do it in a more
conventional approach,
we might only address one
of those objectives once
or a few of them
very superficially.
So this becomes an even more
potent way to make a case,
because you're using the--
you were talking about values.
LARRY SUSSKIND: Use the
objectives against them.
[LAUGHING]
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Yes,
I call it playing judo.
You use your opponent's strength
and speed to your advantage.
LARRY SUSSKIND: Right.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Yeah.
LARRY SUSSKIND: When I
teach graduate students who
are in a professional
degree program, all of this
is easily talked about.
It's layered into the social
objectives, the social change
impact.
It's all easily included
in the conversation.
And there's explicit reflection
on the social impact,
social implications,
social change, or who wins,
who loses if you
do this, and so on.
It's just fascinating
to me that you're
teaching teachers or teaching
kids in elementary school.
And you're, in a sense,
teaching the same thing.
And you're not really
modulating that much.
You're still saying,
there's biases here.
Everyone has a bias.
And you learn what
you're including,
what you're not including.
And it sounds like you would
say that to every level
and to the teachers
teaching at every level.
And that was surprising
to me, that all of this
was as explicit
in your curriculum
in your teaching for K-12, as
it is in teaching professionals.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Yeah.
Let me give you
a couple examples
to say, yes, to support
what you're saying.
So there are a number
of courses that one
might find in an undergraduate
or pre-service art education
curriculum.
You can imagine, there has to
be a 101 or Art Education 101,
Intro.
And then there has
to be the student
teaching at the other end.
And somewhere in there,
there's a practicum course.
Many places have
methods courses.
There's usually a history
course or a cultural practices
or a cultural
foundations course.
And there's also a
curriculum course.
And it depends on what
institution where I'm teaching.
But usually if it's
the curriculum course
or the cultural and
social foundations
course, the first day of class,
this is how I start the class.
Now we've known each other
for almost two years now.
And we've sat through
these conversations.
So you know what I look like.
You know what I sound like.
But imagine students
who are just showing up
to class for the first time.
And this is how I
start the class.
(BRITISH ACCENT) Good afternoon.
My name is Dr. Carpenter,
and I'll be your instructor
this semester.
So for the next
16 weeks, we'll be
engaging in curriculum and
cultural and social issues
related to art education.
Now some of you
come to the course
as artists and others
come as-- and I
continue in just this way.
And we start to
read the syllabus.
And at a certain point,
I just can't do this.
I cannot find different regions
of the UK to move around
my accent.
And certain students
start saying, look.
And then I say, (NO
ACCENT) well, now
the next thing that
we're going to do,
and I change my voice like this.
And they're looking at
me like, oh, my goodness.
What's going on?
And I stop them right there.
This is the first
day of class, Larry.
You haven't blinked in a minute.
And your mouth is wide
open, and you're giggling.
And what's going on here?
And I make them talk.
I say, what's up?
Well, you sound different.
I sound different than what?
Well, you sound different
than you did before.
Well, what did I
sound like before?
Well, you sounded--
you had an accent.
Oh, I did?
What kind of accent?
I say, well, if I'm someplace
else, I have an accent there.
But when I'm home, I
don't have an accent.
People who sounded like that
at home don't have an accent.
It's only when they leave.
And so what else is different?
And they also end up
talking about, well--
I move them to the
space to say, faces
that look like mine, in
most people's conception,
at least in the
institutions where I teach,
don't sound like that.
Or the conception of someone
with an accent like that
looks different than I do.
But I put it on the table,
and I draw attention
to what this
pigmentation looks like
and what it sounds like (BRITISH
ACCENT) to talk like this.
Or if I talk like
this or have a--
so the idea of how accents
inform and influence--
LARRY SUSSKIND: Biases.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: --biases.
That's it.
Day one.
I say, so how do you sound
when you talk to your students?
How does your language--
how does the way you dress
speak to your students?
And also, how do you
respond to your students
based on what they sound
like and what they--
day one.
LARRY SUSSKIND:
And you wouldn't--
I mean, that's not keyed to the
age or level of the students.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Yeah.
So this becomes part of what
it means to be a teacher.
So if you're interested
in teaching learners,
you have multiple
identities in that space.
But if you're going to
assume that all learners are
learners are learners,
it's much easier.
You just deliver
stuff and expect it
to come back in the same way.
It's not messy at all.
For the younger ones, I'm
also spending this year
as an artist and
learner in residence
at an elementary
school in my town.
So I visit a class
of first graders
just about every Friday.
And then I'm working with
the entire third grade team.
LARRY SUSSKIND: [INAUDIBLE].
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
No, that's OK.
Yeah.
Well, it's funny you
say that, because one
of the things I've been
doing with the third graders
is looking at the water crisis.
And I know some of you are
interested in the global water
crisis.
So in third grade, Africa is one
of their social studies units.
It worked out really
quite well in connection
with the African
diaspora water curriculum
that I've been working on that
was funded by the Africana
Research Center at Penn State.
And so to talk to them about
the water crisis in Africa,
there's a moment in
which, for some learners
and for some teachers, there
could be a moment where
you equate Africa, no water.
All Africans have no water.
Right?
I have to call that out.
There's also a moment where--
and this happens
beyond third grade--
it happens in the news.
It happens in TV shows.
It happens in textbooks.
It happens in
daily conversation,
where people will say, I'm going
on a trip, multiple places.
I'm going to fly to France.
And I'm going to go to Germany,
and I'm going to go to Africa.
Really?
You're going to go to a
country, country, continent,
where we frame Africa
as an entire country.
And for those third
graders to learn that,
to learn what I mean by that, to
learn that Africa is a country?
No, Africa is one continent
made up of multiple countries.
Somehow, that doesn't
always happen.
And so the message
then in society
is one that needs
to be attended to.
I mean, it certainly
then lends itself
to biases or misunderstandings
about the continent.
So I make it clear
to the third graders.
But this how I do it.
And I put a map
of Africa and say,
so here's the country of Africa.
And we're going to talk-- no!
What do you mean it's not--
with a little bit of joking,
with a little teasing,
to make sure.
And I enable them and
allow them to make explicit
what they're hearing.
And to continue to do
that is quite important.
There's a book by
Walter Bateman.
He wrote, I think,
after he retired
from the College of Education--
I think it was at
University of Minnesota--
it's called Teaching
Through Inquiry.
And one of the
strategies that he
uses that I borrow, or he
writes about in this book,
is based on the Socratic method.
But it's also based in
this notion of inquiry
through the process of asking
questions one can reveal.
But to make sure students
are paying attention,
you can provide information as
factual, factual, not factual,
factual, and see when and
how they pick up on it.
And I love doing that
with the younger kids.
Or when it's time to share--
so then another
component is I've
been sharing with the students
design challenges that
are drawn directly from
lack of adequate access
to water in different
countries in Africa,
as exemplified from
different places.
So whether it's the water filter
or pumping water or piping
water or transporting water or
collecting water out of the air
through the moisture.
So I say, look,
here's an example.
Imagine you live
in a rural town.
And you have an amazing
access to water,
but it's filled with disease and
mosquito larvae and all this.
I'd like you to design a
way to filter that water.
But you can't use
any electricity.
And you can't use
any oil or any gas,
no motive of motion or power,
other than the human body.
Divide into a group of two,
three, four and draw this.
And I give them 10 minutes.
These are eight-
and nine-year-olds.
And they go away
and they draw it.
And then when they share
these things-- this
the same challenge that you
give that designers are dealing
with in the world right now.
Their drawings are incredible.
Their design-- the conversations
they're having are incredible.
But the way frame it is,
imagine you lived in a town,
blah, blah, blah.
I don't say, imagine you
lived in this African village.
And to take it away from that--
although they are
studying Africa,
I take it away from that and
make it a more generic space
for them to think through.
Then I say, well, in
certain countries in Africa,
this is the case, just like in
certain states in this country,
just like in other
countries in the world.
So I don't just leave it there.
Making it explicit
with the students
is very, very important.
And they get it.
LARRY SUSSKIND: I'm
still on this idea
that there's this special
quality about being a socially
disruptive artist or being
a teacher who's trying
to take this into account.
And all the other
things that we try
to help people get
better at teaching
or better at doing
something doesn't
get at this core quality.
I think it is different and
special and scary and other
things.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Yeah, I
think it's all of those things.
I also-- maybe you
recall, I said,
when I'm doing the
water fountain work,
I still get anxious
to approach people.
LARRY SUSSKIND: You don't
know who's going to haul off
and belt you.
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
They might do this.
Watching all these YouTube
videos tells me other people,
this happens to
folks all the time.
But it's the social
engagement that
is an important part of the
materiality of that work,
just like clay is an important
material part of ceramics,
obviously.
And not everybody is
as able with all media
as they would like to be
or teaching and learning
certain content.
So that's just an understanding.
LARRY SUSSKIND:
Yeah, but this is
different in kind than
learning another medium.
I'm terrible, terrible,
terrible at watercolor.
But watch me go when
I do something else.
OK, I can get better at it.
You can teach me to
get better at it.
It isn't I'm not great at it.
I've never been good at it.
But OK, if I put enough effort
in and you give me coaching,
and I try it, and I watch
it, I'll get better.
I just have a sense that
being ready to commit
to engage in public spaces in
something aimed at changing
the way people think about
things that are challenging
their identity is not
something that you can build
the capacity in the same way.
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
So this is how
I want to answer this
question in another way,
because I think
we're going around
on this on the same question.
And I appreciate
the provocations.
So if I think about the
most recent semester where
I taught the participatory
inquiry course, a range
of students in this course--
one student from I
believe she's in sociology
or comparative
literature, perhaps.
Comparative literature--
was not about to perform,
to do the reading in public.
But was very interested
in graphic novels,
comics, visual representation.
And the issue she
was interested in
was this conversation on campus
about unionizing graduate
students.
And so I was kind of
concerned about, well,
how do I perform unionizing
and the political issues there.
And so we talked
about her interest
in graphic novels and comics.
And what she ended up
doing was, essentially, it
was a survey of
sorts asking people
to provide her with
feedback, their perspective
on this issue, on
unionization of grad students,
and with little drop
boxes where they could--
it's almost like those
suggestion boxes.
And she put them in
strategic places,
collected them, and then
made the graphic visual
representation depictions,
almost like cartoon
on these squares, panels.
And then with the
speech bubbles as was
the content from the
anonymous suggestions
that people gave her.
And then she would post
these on bulletin boards.
So you could see this
public display of comments.
She physically put
this in the world.
But she didn't physically
put herself in the world.
Does that make sense?
LARRY SUSSKIND: Yeah.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: So we're
playing to strengths that way.
And that's why the
particulars of what
she was about when
she was interested in
and what she was capable,
that's what that went.
Another student who
was in architecture
was interested in--
so on our campus,
I don't know how
it happens around
Cambridge and around MIT,
but we have different
representatives
from different religions
or different beliefs
who will set up in
different parts of campus.
And they're allowed to do that.
And they'll pass out literature.
And they'll engage
people in conversation.
And so what this
one student did was,
he wanted to emulate their--
he wanted to borrow their
mode of their presentation,
but not their message.
He wanted to actually
substitute out
their message of
religion and spirituality
with concepts from architecture.
And so he [CHUCKLES]--
LARRY SUSSKIND: Sounds
a little strange.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: It is very.
It was, yeah, exactly.
So imagine, you're
walking down the sidewalk
and someone says, oh, may I talk
to you about being saved or may
I talk to you about spiritual
enlightenment or whatever?
And then instead of
doing that, you say,
well, do you have a
moment, because I'd
like to talk to you about the
differences between concrete
and cement and their uses
in architectural structures.
I'm thinking, what?
But he's dressed as if--
LARRY SUSSKIND: It sounds
like a really MIT thing.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Right?
[LAUGHTER]
But he's dressed
as someone that you
might see on campus in
the guise of a spiritual
or a religious practice.
So in that way, he felt
very comfortable doing that.
But it was about, well, how
do you take on that persona
without--
he wasn't trying to [INAUDIBLE].
He was trying to use
that visual as momentum.
LARRY SUSSKIND: Until you
play to his strength--
STEPHEN CARPENTER: You
play to their strengths.
LARRY SUSSKIND: There a
lot of ways of doing this.
You're playing to
people's strengths.
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
That's what it's about.
Yeah.
LARRY SUSSKIND: I like that.